oui non c'est vrai que je suis un peu
trop philippe et parfois qu enfin quand
même moi qui pensais qu'on avait vécu
une grande histoire romantique tous les
deux 5 euros moody's
on s'est rencontré à malabo quand elle
est chargée des résultats les
coloscopies c'est sûr que présentée
comme fort quand je venais dormir chez
toi dans ta succursale de pharmacie
l'aja vrai sentiment de faire des heures
sup non plus le jour tu seras vraiment
malade
merci bien pourquoi tu dis ça et là
c'est vrai [ __ ] j'ai un truc grave tu
as jamais aux iem le dire qu'être grave
et bien sûr accès à leur dossier médical
tu m'as cacher une partie des résultats
mais quel résultat voilà voilà pour que
tu m'as quitté tu voulu plutôt qu paix
d'amour ans je condamne et sam est
contradictoire au hockey pardon excusez
moi mais c'est moi je de mentir à un
moment fendi eliane qu'est-ce que j'ai
ça c'est tout toi ça regarde moi je te
jure tient en très bonne santé
je t'en supplie j'ai droit à la vérité
la vérité c'est que tu m'emmerdes wit
est très malade ou tu vas bientôt mourir
dans d'atroces souffrances voilà tu es
content combien de temps l'homme qu'est
ce que tu oublies